are you ready to become the man who
saved the world from an alien menace
that was I'm gonna kill this all of us I
just need you to pull up your big-girl
pants and only your power we sell the
shoe modified you and resurrected you
they won't even notice it up
they say they come in peace but how long
will it be before these gods decide to
rule instead of sir earth traitors will
buy a calling is something that is
within you
we have a duty to be where we need to
help
you are what we've been waiting for
weena lose our court's decision I'm just
a woman trying to make a name for
herself outside of her fam
and you understand that it's not enough
to defend the world you need to live in
it your traitor to your people not us
against them you have integrity to right
wrongs and to see justice done I can see
the hero within you we have given our
lives protecting the people of our the
ego of gods this is their week
the gates p2 burgesses charlie so new
Supergirl footage for the next couple of
episodes we have president Wonder Woman
that I'll explain in a second it looks
like we got more Superman fortress
solitude and metallo beatdown so here we
go
a nice twist on the idea of taking up
the hero's call like in the first
episode Cara's having trouble figuring
out what she wants to do with her life
moving forward
cat grant gives her this big speech that
gets our all pumped up these two clips
is actually like two trailers jammed
together for the next episode is a twist
on that where you have Cadmus labs
giving metallo the heroes call to action
are you ready to take up the fight
become the hero that saved the human
race so it's just a fun dark twist on
that if the music didn't already tip you
off to that like they start off with a
really dark music the other big thing in
this this might be footage from the next
couple of episodes not just next week's
episode like they did with that flash
footage from last weekend but we see
Lynda Carter as the United States
President so Wonder Woman is the
President of the United States of course
Wonder Woman would be President of the
United States so it seems like they have
like the xenophobia storyline going on
where insidious forces are playing on
people's fears of alien invasion so they
try to create all this drama so
president Wonder Woman comes along and
tries to make everyone chill the hell
out but Supergirl has to protect her
from attacks so it's gonna be a lot of
fun seeing what she does on the show so
I don't know if she's going to be in
episode 2 she might be in episode 3
we'll be seeing her pretty quickly so
look forward to lots of Wonder Woman
Easter eggs when she does show up a
little bit of Fortress of Solitude
action couple really iconic moments from
the comics here you have the birth of
metallo and you have like the death of
Supergirl from crisis on Infinite Earths
if you haven't read that storyline you
probably seen this image before it's one
of like the most famous Supergirl panels
ever and it was basically DC fixing its
continuity what happened is is that post
crisis what they wanted to do with the
character is that they wanted Superman
to be the only survivor of Krypton so
they needed to give Supergirl a
different origin story when they
reintroduced her later so that's how you
got to the matrix
supergirl which is really confusing and
then much much later when they did
Infinite Crisis which was kind of like
the sequel event to crisis on Infinite
Earths if you don't remember Infinite
Crisis don't worry don't you don't need
to go back and read it it gets really
confusing but they rebooted her
continuity again but then they rebooted
her again during the new 52 and it
becomes kind of like a redo version of
the New Krypton arc where she tries to
remake Krypton on earth then she goes
into outer space becomes a Red Lantern
it gets really crazy the new rebirth
version of Supergirl is her as a
teenager in high school and I think it's
going to be a lot more fun it's more in
keeping with the tone of the TV show but
luckily you don't actually have to read
the comics to understand what's going on
a TV show but you'll totally spot these
kinds of iconic moments from the comics
like these are really easy to spot like
oh they are very clearly doing this
comic book cover but the other thing
here is they're just hammering home the
idea the Cadmus labs is the big bad of
this first half of the season they'll
definitely be other villains too films
from outer space we know we're getting
Roulette later in the season she'll be
like one of the other antagonists this
other girl in the trailer it's hard to
tell who she is just based on the way
she's talking to Supergirl she calls her
a traitor to her people so it makes her
sound like she's another Kryptonian the
only other Kryptonian that they could do
that's like a big female character would
be Power Girl there are a lot of
Kryptonians that surface during that new
Krypton arc but you know she could be a
daksa might as part of the Mon L plot
and she could be from candor because I'm
really hoping even if they don't do a
New Krypton arc because they kind of did
that last season with Zod's followers
but I wouldn't be surprised if somehow
Cadmus labs got their hands on the
bottle city of Kandor that'd be pretty
badass you could go a number of
different directions with that storyline
because one you have to save Kandor than
two what would you do if people started
coming back to normal size there'd be
Kryptonians all over the place but that
feels like it get a little ridiculous a
little fast so I don't think they're
going straight to that I think mod L
Superman and Supergirl will be like the
main Kryptonians on the show for the
time being they'll probably be other
superpower people that'll be able to
match their abilities but you don't know
like flood the screen with Kryptonians
all of a sudden so let me know in the
comments what do you think about
hello on the show and how long do you
think it's gonna take before they get to
a bottle city of Kandor storyline I
would totally be okay
if they save that for the second half of
the season or they tease that going into
like season three and it became a big
season three thing because you already
have like so much stuff going on with
the four night crossover that's going to
be the dominators they haven't said
anything about the DAX might's
even though Monell is ad Aksumite he's
from the place that the daksa mites live
in the comics that that special nebula
that they talked about in the episode
and we have like the big flash crossover
in the second half of the season there's
like that musical episode they've been
talking about but they've already teased
like so many big action set pieces
throughout the season big characters
that I feel like they'll probably hold
off on bottle city of Kandor but
anything could happen one of the cool
things about like the DC CW shows is
that all the show runners of all the
different shows have said that Greg
Berlanti is the guy who's like oh you
have like a big storyline that you want
to do for the finale well move that up
and think of something new to do during
the finale so like flashpoint on the
flash for instance a lot of conventional
TV shows might have spent like six or
seven episodes maybe an entire season in
that flashpoint storyline but greg
berlanti the flash people just like blow
past it move up the conclusion of that
story and go on to something else think
of something more interesting to do
after that so usually one of the
tell-tale signs of a boring show is when
they do not burn through plot really
fast so flash burns through plot
Supergirl burning through plot just
showing you they're not wasting any time
doing the really big really WTF awesome
stuff so get hype new episode of the
flash posting tonight episode two
they're introducing the tom Felton
character he's playing Julian Albert
I'll explain dr. alchemy stuff when I
post that there'll be all kinds of dr.
alchemy stuff that we'll talk about this
season it's gonna be a lot of fun so be
sure to subscribe to get that there is a
new round of the DC giveaway that's
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll just remind everyone
when I post that flash video tonight
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my flash killer frost
trailer for that episode tonight you can
click here for my Supergirl at
so one easter egg video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you